1415 and seyuta which is here had just
fallen to the portuguese this conquest
was led by king john the first of
portugal who was seeking loot and to
control the straits of gibraltar the
northern side being dominated by the
kingdom of castile
this straight controlled trade flowing
in and out of the mediterranean which
was important because portugal as you
can see was not in the mediterranean and
wanted to be guaranteed access to its
trade routes
a bit of background the iberian
peninsula at this time was divided into
five different entities
on the atlantic coast was portugal in
the middle of the peninsula was castile
to the north
was navarre to the south the islamic
emirate of granada and on the
mediterranean coast was the kingdom of
aragon
the two kingdoms responsible for most of
the exploring in the period were castile
which was very wealthy
and portugal which had a strong naval
tradition expansion around this time was
intermittent and was often due to the
patronage of wealthy individuals often
monarchs
in the case of portugal much was due to
henry the navigator whose sponsorship
allowed portugal to claim and settle
madeira and the azores
his patronage also funded portuguese
exploration of africa and by 1445 most
of the north western coast of africa had
been explored
the portuguese had a monopoly on the
trade from this region and to protect it
they built coastal and island forts from
which they operated
these were called fytorias and
essentially acted as trading ports
warehouses and military garrisons and
gave portugal huge influence in the
surrounding areas
the trade from west africa was mostly
meager until 1471 when the portuguese
sailed down to what is now modern day
ghana
here they found a trading network rich
in gold ivory and slaves
this made many portuguese traders very
rich and at first they tried to keep
this trade a secret which of course
didn't happen because wealth has a
tendency of getting noticed
in this case by the castilians wealth
was one of the main reasons for
exploration and would soon become an
important tax revenue for many european
kingdoms
there were other reasons however
religion played a huge part in pushing
exploration many christians felt
compelled to convert the natives of far
away lands
christians were also searching for
presta john a mythical christian king
from either africa or asia who they
wanted to ask for help in a crusade
castile had done some of its own
exploring and colonising by this point
and have been slowly conquering the
canary islands
castilian ships were also following the
portuguese down the coast of africa and
trading as well
during the war of the castilian
succession which saw isabella proclaim
the queen of castile
the portuguese and castilian fleets
often fought off the coast of africa
isabella was married to ferdinand the
king of aragon and together they
conquered the emirate of granada in 1492
uniting most of the peninsula and
forming the bases of spain
for the sake of simplicity both castile
and aragon will be referred to as
spanish but they were technically
distinct kingdoms
so portuguese and spanish exploration
really kicked off towards the end of the
15th century due to the new technology
of triangular sails
these sails allowed ships to sail into
the wyndham further than ever before
which precipitated a major rise in
explorative voyages which were mostly
dominated by sailors from venice genoa
portugal and castile
the portuguese moved further and further
down the coast of africa until
bartolomeudia sailed around the southern
tip of africa in 1488
opening up the indian ocean to
exploration the most famous voyage of
the era occurred in 1492 and christopher
columbus a genoan sailed under the
patronage of castile and aragon and
discovered the new world
landing in the bahamas although he
believed he had landed in asia
next was vasco de garma who in 1498
sailed all the way around africa and
landed in india after him was amerigo
vespucci who sailed to brazil and
demonstrated that the new world was in
fact not asia
america's name would later form the
basis of america the name for this new
continent
in 1500 pedro gabriel discovered brazil
before traveling to india as well
columbus's attempt to find a route to
asia and togama search for a route to
india were due to the desire to
circumvent the ottoman empire
the ottomans had expanded quickly during
the 15th century and in 1453 had put an
end to the byzantine empire when they
conquered constantinople
many europeans weren't keen on trading
with an islamic power which profited
from them as such many europeans look
for ways around the ottomans to save
money and avoid having to trade with
muslims so portugal and spain having
invested so much in exploring wanted
returns for their efforts and so
approached the greatest moral authority
of the time the pope
for guarantees various popes gave
guarantees but eventually the portuguese
and castilian monarchs made their own
agreement this agreement the treaty of
tordesillas divided the world between
spain and portugal
this agreement was quickly ignored by
other european powers but it did help
direct both castile and portugal
both wanted power and wealth but the
ways they built their empires were
fundamentally different
the spanish built what could be said is
a more traditional territorial empire
there are a lot of individual conquests
but the two best known were those by the
conquistadors hernan cortes who
conquered the aztec empire
and francisco pizarro who conquered the
incas so cortes landed in what is now
mexico in 1519 having been ordered by
the governor of cuba to not do exactly
that
the aztec empire that dominated mexico
was not some grand unified state
it was comprised of subject states which
paid tribute often in the form of humans
for sacrifice to the aztecs and their
ruler who was called the talatawani
his name was mokta zuma ii and lived in
the aztec capital of tenochtitlan which
had a population of roughly a quarter
million people
after making contact with the aztecs
cortes made his way through the aztec
tributary states such as the
semi-independent talaxcolons who saw the
spanish arrival as an opportunity to
overthrow their aztec overlords
after making alliances and a little bit
of fighting cortes took a small force of
his men to tenochtitlan where he was
greeted by moktu zuma who soon found
himself essentially a spanish puppet
whilst cortez was in tanoptietlan a man
called panfilo de narvaez arrived on the
coast of mexico to arrest him for
defying the cuban governor
cortes left the aztec captain and gave
narvaez his men a reason to join him
that reason was gold cortez returned to
tenochtitlan which was in revolt against
him and during the fighting moktuzuma
was killed along with roughly 800
conquistadors
cortes fled to lax cala where they were
reinforced and planned a counter-attack
at this point the aztec grip on their
empire was severely diminished and with
the help of many former aztec subjects
the spanish laid siege to tanochte laam
which had recently had an outbreak of
smallpox
the combined spanish native force won
decisively and the aztec empire was
annexed
over the next decade more spanish
conquistadors arrived rebelling peoples
was subjugated and central america
became the viceroyalty of new spain
a decade after cortez's victory pizarro
and a group of conquistadors landed here
in what was then the incan empire
the incas were at the time undergoing a
civil war over the succession of the
throne which was won by a certain atahua
alper
pizarro invited atahualpa to meet him
and 150 of his men at a place called
kayamaka which atahua alpha agreed to
when he arrived pizarro sprung his trap
capturing the incan leader and holding
him for ransom before executing him the
year after
this ransom was huge so huge it took two
years to deliver
this made the conquistadors
exceptionally rich and thus the incan
empire very poor
the incan empire never recovered from
this and over the next few decades it
disintegrated and was incorporated into
the spanish empire as part of the vice
royalty of peru
it was from south america that spain got
famously wealthy from the silver
mines there which they extracted via the
use of native labor expansion of empire
did not mean the end of exploration and
in 1519 ferdinand magellan began the
first successful circumnavigation of the
globe
he didn't see the end of the voyage
though since he decided to stop off at
the philippines in order to be murdered
portugal's approach was markedly
different from spain's after vasco de
gama's initial journey the portuguese
made almost yearly voyages into the
indian ocean with fleets
called armadas to conduct trade missions
in fact cabral was leading one of these
armadas when brazil was discovered in
1500
the portuguese did settle brazil shortly
afterwards which was an important source
of lumber but since there was no gold
there the portuguese focused on the land
surrounding the indian ocean instead
one aspect of portuguese power that
differed from spain was that it was
overwhelmingly focused on the navy
this meant that pushing deep inland like
the spanish did was unfeasible
instead portugal established what has
been called a trading post empire
whereby many fitorius were created along
the coasts of the indian ocean
and from them the mighty portuguese navy
operated portugal's navy was important
in shaping indian ocean trade when the
kartai system was established
under this system sailors and traders
would pay portugal for a license and in
return portugal would keep them safe
from hostile states and pirates failing
to pay the car ties would lead to either
ships being refused passage
having their goods seized or being
attacked the car ties alongside the
strength of the portuguese navy gave
portugal dominance over indian ocean
trade this upset the ottomans who tried
to remove the portuguese but ultimately
failed in 1510 under the command of a
man called alfonzo to albuquerque the
portuguese captured goa which became a
strategically important outpost the next
year he conquered malacca giving
portugal control over the straits of
malacca
an important choke point in the
lucrative spice trading network
in 1542 the portuguese established
contact and trade with the japanese and
in 1557 portugal was leaked macau in
china from which they traded
it wasn't just portugal in southeast
asia since in 1564 spain also conquered
the philippines
brazil was not entirely ignored during
this time either french explorers
started smuggling brazil with back to
europe and even settled on the coast
there
this forced the portuguese to begin
formal colonisation and to make sure the
french stopped coming back
they simply paid them brazil would later
become extremely important to the
portuguese economy as a massive importer
of slaves from africa
these empires brought huge amounts of
wealth back to both spain and portugal
tipping the european balance of power
spain under carlos the first and
philippe ii became europe's most
powerful
country this was primarily because of
the masses of silver that were imported
from the new world back to europe as
well as the money made in trade with
africa
wealthy kingdoms tend to make enemies
and spain and portugal were no different
the spanish soon found themselves odd
with the french the english the
portuguese and later the dutch
these costly wars alongside the
declining value of silva meant that
spain gradually became poorer but
ultimately would remain the most
powerful european nation for several
more decades the portuguese were
slightly better avoiding european wars
and its power didn't wane until the
iberian union which occurred when king
sebastian died
this led to a conflict which philippe of
spain won making him the king of
portugal as well
this made spain's enemies portugals and
thus other european powers began to grab
some of portugal's colonies
in conclusion the portuguese and spanish
were the first out of the gates when it
came to empire building their empires
are ultimately complex and should not be
seen as merely good or uniformly evil
whilst conquest and destruction did
occur widely they also opened world
trade to europeans which for better or
worse made
the world we live in today i hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching